so it has been one month since millions
of lives were uprooted and destroyed by
the two powerful earthquakes That Shook
Southern turkey and Northwest Syria the
full extent of the catastrophe is now
very evident more than 50 000 people
have died across both countries and
millions of displaced and many are still
searching for their missing relatives
from hate elf URL begins our coverage
called a cemetery of the unknown it's
one of the many where those who lost
their lives in earthquakes in southern
turkey are buried
but their identities were never recorded
like lots of others tubakara has been
asked to give a DNA test and apply to
authorities for any news of her husband
we still could not get any news about
him we cannot reach him from anywhere we
looked at every place we're supposed to
even to the cemeteries
I don't know if someone took him to a
hospital or maybe he lost his memory
because we cannot find him anywhere
in the weeks after the Quakes struck
many of the Dead were buried without
being identified now their relatives are
trying to find them Maryam yildes from
hatai is a mother of three she saved two
of her three children but her
seven-year-old son chadash is still
missing
I don't think he's dead I've never felt
he's dead I believe my son will come
back to me safe and sound
Mariam says she heard from witnesses
that her son was pulled out from under
debris alive
some old lady told me a boy looking like
my son was taken by some people but she
didn't know who they were
to find a missing person family members
give samples of their dnas to the police
and wait for them to check their records
photos and DNA swaps taken from the dead
have been recorded since the first day
of the disaster the government hasn't
officially said how many people are
still missing many family members are
trying to find their loved ones by
putting ads like these in different
parts of the city they're hoping that
someone will recognize them so they can
be reunited again
joins us live from the epicenter of the
first quirk in caramel marash and hasha
met one month on but a long long road
still ahead
indeed wherever you travel you see
distraction of biblical proportions
across 11 provinces
in southern part of turkey and every day
is the same constant struggle by the
local communities they're trying to pick
up the pieces and move on they're
struggling with a wide array of
challenges the need to find their loved
ones who are buried under the rubble
pick up some of the valuables in their
homes
ID cards bottles of olive oil whatever
they can salvage from under the rubble
as we're going to see in this report
[Music]
the moment has been waiting for
excavators clear the rubble she only has
a few hours to salvage whatever she can
[Music]
she has spent most of her life here and
now she has to confront the harsh
reality
I'm here with my family to collect
anything that would help me connect with
the past so that the memories of the
place and the people I met lives on this
was once my house
the authorities keep safe deposit boxes
recovered from the rubble in police
stations
owners have to provide detailed lists of
their belongings which should match at
least findings
to retrieve whatever they can from the
debris identity cars Furniture jewelry
and money and sometimes all they want is
only the medicine they left behind as
they rush to survive the devastation the
reason they're taking risks is the fear
this could be their last chance to
recover whatever they can before is
forever gone
right after the earthquakes hit 11
provinces in southern turkey Security
Forces launched a Crackdown on robbers
and rounded uploaders
they also managed to retrieve cash and
gold bars from destroyed Banks and
jewelry shops
[Music]
is recovering his brother's belongings
he was rescued along with his family but
seven other families didn't make it
what can you do you feel completely
helpless in the face of Calamity I found
a few items mostly photos of my brother
and his children he has at least a few
memories now to keep with him
it's all about keeping memories alive
and remembering those who couldn't make
it mostly buried in unmarked Graves
we're talking about the visible scars
that you see on the ground the mountains
of rubble the destruction and the
devastation but there's absolutely no
way we'll be ever able to Fathom the
sense of emotional scars those who are
now struggling with the shattered lies
their loved ones who disappeared during
the earthquake people are now just
looking forward to move on they know
that this is going to be a long journey
ahead they will move to container
shelters with a promise by the
government than that within a year from
now they will be able to finally find a
permanent shelter that the government
says is going to be safer better and
stronger but what a journey for all
those people who walk up one day and
just within
120 seconds they lost everything
indeed such a tough time for all
throughout this tragedy uh Hashem thanks
for that reporting there
okay my colleague Tom McRae spoke to
Lucy Jones who is a world-renowned
seismologist and she says that
earthquake building regulations and
preparedness have become more important
for turkey
before this big Quake how would you have
rated turkey as a preparedness for a big
earthquake like this obviously it's on a
major fault line everyone knew that it
was going to be prone to to having a
large earthquake we've seen many
earthquakes over the the last couple of
decades
um you know in Turkey so how would you
rate their preparedness for something
like this and then how is it stacked up
with what you've seen play out there are
more people there than I expected
beforehand because because of the um the
code is very good the engineers are very
good we've I worked with a lot of
Turkish Engineers they're very much part
of the International Community and
that's why I want to see have we missed
something in creating the code or not
turkey in terms of scientific
understanding and Engineering expertise
it's up there with with the rest of the
world because they know they have a
problem they've had a lot of really
dedicated scientists working to it and
this is where I feel like I don't know
how much it's the lack of enforcement of
the code and how much the international
code really has failed and really hasn't
understood what these type of
earthquakes could be because we haven't
had a major strike slip earthquake with
modern Construction in the modern code
uh since the code is really adopted in
the last 20 years so the studies are
going to be important
and you can see the full interview with
seismologist Lucy Jones that is at the
1430 GMT are right here on Al Jazeera
So In Rebel controlled parts of
Northwestern Syria survivors are still
waiting for Vital Aid due to
restrictions imposed by President bash
al-assad's government is an aid worker
and explains what still needs to be done
to help those in need
[Music]
I am working in the humanitarian field
in this region in the northwest of Syria
foreign
which had a long period of War for about
12 years at this region in the northwest
of Syria has a very weak or fragile
infrastructure one of the difficulties
all the organizations had in this region
is about the
Border Gates in such a crisis or
catastrophe they should be first aid
responses
we responded by immediately in the same
day even to distribute
carpets and blankets and
places for homeless people and hot meals
and even eating materials and lately
uh we we had our big project as a whole
town which was
originally designed for displaced people
but we used it for people who were
damaged by the earthquake we responded
to 1
000 family were rehousing in this town
and we are still supporting them as much
as possible
[Music]